author tony halsey coates is joining us
this hour with a discussion about an
issue that we tend to associate with the
past the attempted banning of books here
in america
these ten books were the most quote
challenged books last year so that means
someone attempted to get them banned
usually at a public library or school
four of the ten deal specifically with
race and racism three were ultimately
banned in some communities for three
years in a row the most challenged book
has been banned for lgbtqia
plus content in 2020 one of the banned
books was between the world and me and
that's why tahasi coates is here for
this discussion he's also part of an
event this week with the authors of
several other banned works including
ibram x kindy and nicole hannah jones
todd haasey coates we're going to move
on from football and talk about books
okay so let's let's look at this four of
the top 10 books were banned because of
it's called anti-black racism is that a
coincidence to you what do you make of
that no i don't think it's a coincidence
at all i think for most of american
history uh african-american authors have
not had the purchase on the american
conscience that they have right now
we've always talked among ourselves uh
mostly the dialogue in terms of books
has been amongst ourselves you're at a
moment where you know people like
ibrahim kindy people like nicole hannah
jones they're reaching a lot of people
even sells a lot of books the 1619
project was seen by a lot of people so
this is really about white people and
particularly white children now being
exposed to ideas that i think previously
were segregated frankly so does it make
parents and teachers uncomfortable is
that why do you think it's happening i
don't know that it even makes
parents and teachers uncomfortable i
think it makes um
certain politicians in our system
uncomfortable um the 1619 project was
cited in a uh executive order um there
are laws for instance passed in texas
that specifically mentioned this work so
this is the state this isn't just you
know local i don't know exactly i don't
want my kid reading this this is
actually state action uh banning some of
this work what are the stakes in this
fight
um
i think it's the political imagination
which is a big term
but uh we think about going into the
voting booth you know to make choices
about what policies what politicians we
want but you can't understand for
instance why health care should be a
human right if you don't understand
history if you don't understand uh the
context in which things happen if you
can't put your yourself in the shoes of
somebody that doesn't have health care
that's what books do they expand the
political imagination they let you know
what you're actually voting for in the
first place i want to get back to your
book between the world and me which is
about being black in america it was
challenged and banned what was your
reaction to that when you heard the news
well actually i just heard this today
in fact just in fact we were talking in
the green room i mean obviously i've
known for years that it's been banned
for instance in prisons you know and i
get occasional things about it being
banned in schools but the big one i
actually heard about was we were eight
years in power but it was a teacher down
in uh tennessee matt hahn who was fired
for teaching an essay in in in there and
that's just part of a wave that is
happening you know it is you know state
legal action to you know really prevent
certain ideas from being into you know
uh entering into the mainstream
conversation but i like nate's question
though because what is your reaction
here you have this best-selling book
yeah that has been really widely
acclaimed and well very well received
here that your work is being banned um
so i'll be fine yeah
between the world to be sold a lot of
books i'm okay i'm still getting my
royalty checks um i'm sorry for kids you
know one of the things i was saying you
know back when we were talking before is
my consciousness and my sense of the
world was not just formed by black
authors and by authors who validated my
world but by authors who challenged you
know i mean authors in fact who at this
very day i will tell you were cold
racist but i needed to know i needed to
know what the world is and so when you
start saying to a kid
or your kids i only want you to read
things that validate my point of view
that's no longer education that's
indoctrination but i'm trying to figure
out tonight why your book was banned do
you know have you been given a reason
about why the book was banned i have to
be honest i have not interrogated it too
much but if i had to guess i think it
goes back to what we were saying at the
top to this point about education versus
indoctrination i think it's important to
point out that people on the right
politicians would say they're the ones
being canceled and shut out they're not
included in conversation and when you're
endorsing a wide range of ideas you're
saying in an educational environment you
should be able to read just about
anybody right right yes i totally
totally agree with that and as i said
before um it is very much the books that
challenge my point of view um that you
know i think are dead wrong and actually
helpful in my consciousness i would make
a big differentiation we have not seen a
political movement in state legislatures
for instance uh in executive orders that
actually target work that's happening to
a particular band of work and that
hasn't happened as much on the right if
it did i would be as opposed to that
real quick before we go what's your
message to parents who might be hearing
about this what can they do in order to
expose their kids to a wide range of
ideas and books i think parents can read
themselves there you go i think parents
can read themselves i think that's the
biggest thing i think you can educate
yourself you know and avoid your own
indoctrination well said thank you so
much tanasi coates we appreciate you